hello everyone and welcome to a really
wonderful game uh from the 1988 uh world
cup uh it's a game between yasser
zeravan and alexander beliavsky two very
well known figures in the chess world
and uh since you guys enjoyed
yesterday's video uh that was also a
very short game i thought i'd throw in
another one this one is not as short it
is a bit longer but it features a really
really awesome attack uh so you guys are
showing
are gonna enjoy it uh that being said
let's check it out and also if you guys
can make it uh today we have a alicia's
arena starts 8 30 uh central european
time the link is in the description
below first thing you will see uh let's
enjoy the game uh so yasser with the
white pieces opens with d4 uh we have d5
by belowsky c4 c6 knight to c3 and
knight to f6 uh going for the uh slav
defense we have c capture some d5c
captures and bishop to f4 now
we have knights the c6 by black and the
white just continues with e3
you can't really go for something like
this to take advantage because you run
into a very very well-known uh trap by
black not even queen to a5 but rather e5
and this is just game over
because now if bishop captures an e5 you
have this knight to e4 move and now you
have very nice control of the c3 square
bishop to be for check is coming and
white has to very very quickly abandon
whatever he was doing and try uh to
consolidate because if you go for knight
to c7 check uh it seems like yes
everything is fine but you just captured
the knight there's no problem bishop
captures bishop b for check and now the
queen has to step in front of the king
you'll you'll just pick up the queen
with check king to d1 now even knight
captures an f2 check and that's just it
you're donna uh white is down a full
rook and it's game over so after knight
to c6 with e3 uh and now comes bishop to
f5 so also getting some nice development
in we have knight to f3 and now e6 and
here uh bishop to b5 just pinning that
knight maybe preparing knight to e5 so
black takes care of that he plays knight
to d7 now this knight is no longer
pinned and also black has very nice
control of the e5 square so here uh uh
servant castles and bishop to a7 uh
seems like white is also preparing the
castle and the white pro black probably
would castle white continue with
something like rook to c1 then we'd see
castles and you know the game continues
however here uh servant played bishop
captures in c6 and it's already uh
maybe capturing for for the sake of
capture so we have uh b captures on c6
and now rook to c1 so okay you will have
uh this uh backwards c6 pawn is a target
so belovsky defends it and now we have
knight to a4 not allowing any
uh immediate c5 ideas so you really like
this pawn to be stuck here on c6
but this allows uh belawski to
completely abandon any ideas of castling
and go straight for the attack and i i
don't remember what live stream it was i
know uh yasser was streaming that it was
i think maybe two years ago or maybe
three years ago and he said that
you don't want to give your opponent
your home address uh too soon because
then he will know where you live and he
will come and visit you and this is
exactly what yasser did here
he castled uh and then he continued
playing here maybe on the queen side uh
but that doesn't um
work all that great with this position
so here bellavsky just plays g5 and now
we know what's coming h4 is coming h5 h4
and what can white do here well of
course you have to move the bishop so
either bishop to e5 or bishop to g3 g3
makes a little bit more sense uh so h5
preparing h4 to trap this bishop and now
comes h3 of course we have to create
some breeding room for a bishop here but
now g4 uh so again what do you play here
uh we have uh h captures on g4 there is
one game where knight to the e5 was
played a black won that game but here h
captures on g4 and it is now as of move
15 that this position has never been
reached again so h captures on g4
attacks the knight now now we have to go
to e5 knight to e5 you could also go to
h2 but that looks like a really weird
square uh for the knight um for example
knight here okay you're attacking the g
for pawn uh but after knight to f6
defending it that knight is stuck there
i mean it's um
maybe something you don't want to do so
instead he played knights the e5 and the
idea is the same we're attacking the g4
pawn so uh black of course will
eliminate this knight so knight captures
on e5 bishop captures an e5 attacking
the rook and now f6 that's the good
stuff uh bishop back to g3 and now we
reach the position from the thumbnail
where the black king announces checkmate
he says uh king to f7
and that's pretty much all uh that black
needs to do here now the thread is just
we move the rook we double up on the h
file and we deliver rook to h1 checkmate
so is there any way for white to prevent
this uh doesn't seem like it uh sarawan
played rook to e1 trying to make some
room for the king to
try and escape to the center of the
board we still continue rook to h5 and
now queen to d2 uh probably making room
for the king all the way on d1 but it's
uh maybe also even trying to get another
defender if the bishop to b4 comes in
because these bishops are very very
strong if this bishop ever comes to b4
could be even stronger okay you have
this retreat with knight to c3
but i guess he wanted to
keep the knight there if uh if it all
needed to to maybe come to c5 uh and now
you could continue with queen to h8
which was your initial plan but now for
example king to f1 uh bishop to b4 and
now knight to c3 uh it's unclear how to
continue this uh attack well it's it's
not that unclear but uh belovsky just
started with um uh this uh incredible
move right away so instead after queen
to d2 he didn't go for queen to h8 he
instead played bishop to e4 and this is
just a monster move uh because it
prepares such a such a beauty that you
guys are really really gonna enjoy this
one so king to f1 of course we want to
bring our king over to d1 to try and
keep it safe there but now feel free to
pause the video and really end the game
for white while i give you a couple of
seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on finding this
brilliancy and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is of course
bishop the f3 uh there are other moves
that win this position but bishop to f3
is just game over it's the first mate in
four so it was in this position on move
21 that yasser sereman resigned in the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here you take away the e2 square from
the white king and now rook to h1 will
just be checkmate and even if you
capture the bishop captures captures uh
the pawn still covers the e2 and g2
squares rook to h1 will be checkmate and
now after king to g1 uh you have many
ways of winning this uh you could just
go queen to h8 and now rook to h1 is
unstoppable or if you want to really be
cool you can also just sacrifice the
rook first then king captures and then
the bring the queen into the
h file with temple king g1 now queen to
h3 and now you're getting checkmated so
a very nice 21 move game uh by alexander
beliavsk against an incredibly strong
opponent uh like castro cerevan balofsky
finished in shared third place and the
tournament was won by none other than
anatoly karpov but still a great great
achievement and especially this game
it's a really quite a beauty so uh here
you can see that uh
castling is important but castling too
early and then you know not um
continuing in the style of your of your
castle position can uh you know bring to
a very very sudden downfall like it
happened here because uh those uh g5
especially when you have the knight and
bishop here they're just you know free
tempe for the pawns just attack attack
attack
just everything is coming forward and
you will not have time to consolidate so
maybe something to consider in your own
games
and that's it hope you guys uh enjoyed
this one uh like i said uh do join us
today it's going to be a lot of fun an
hour and a half of delecias arena i
think we already have uh almost a
thousand players registered for the
tournament so uh do do join us uh so
yeah once again hope you guys uh enjoyed
it uh i would like to thank tom daralo
and michael schmidty uh bearis uh airtel
uh michael kennedy and young wokowski
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it as
usual you can check to all my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon uh continuing to check
up on your wonderful suggestions and
everything else that's happening in the
chess world uh thank you i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day